hi everyone my name is vague and I'm
flan we are your senior class officers
welcome to the class day 2020 experience
first and foremost we really hope
everyone is safe and healthy this is
obviously not what we envisioned when we
picture at the end of our time at Yale
these last few weeks were supposed to be
some of the best and instead they've
been some of the toughest but those lost
weeks will not be what defines the class
of 2020 no we're the class that pressed
on in spite of the virus and all the
barriers that have brought we made
tick-tocks have zoom happy hours we
passionately advocated for you P more
than that we had an incredible 3.75
years together on campus and stayed
together virtually in that last quarter
we are still connected despite the
physical distance that this pandemic has
forced on us we will not be the class
that simply lost our seniors spring but
instead the one that persevered through
all the adversity that we faced our time
at Yale has been marked by momentous
change we are among the last first years
to experience Commons in all its
traditions in glory and we will
hopefully be the last class to hear
jokes that TD is so far we were the
first to have heads of college first
years and Harper College Yale memes for
special snowflake teams was founded when
we got here they were witness to the
unforgettable one phone November 2016
when we won our first harvard-yale game
in ten years and then went on to win two
more then senior year happened and we
learned how much this class left a party
we kick things off with opening night
and we had two open bars but we realized
we needed to upgrade pretty soon and so
we did to 12 at masquerade we had
Oktoberfest a month after Oktoberfest is
supposed to happen and we finished
things off with our wine and cheese
night at the Yale Center for British art
which is definitely the kind of event
that I expected to have more of it you
know and before you ask I'm sorry it is
too late to get your senior sticker all
those big moments would not have been
complete without the smaller ones
from Jonesy late night staying way too
long in a buttery livin on a prayer to
close out loads to IMS the bonds we
formed and the memories we made together
will be what define our time at Yale
from academics to club's
residential colleges and the arts
cultural centers and athletic teams
there are people and friendships that
have helped us through Yale and will
continue to help us throughout our lives
this is how our class will be remembered
so congratulations to the class of 2020
we are so excited to see what the future
holds for all of us even though our
in-person celebration is gonna have to
wait a little bit we can graduate
knowing that we have each other to help
us get there and when we do I think
we're gonna need to have more than 12
open bars in the meantime we will
continue to celebrate your hard work
despite this change will now move on to
the class state committee who've worked
tirelessly to modify the traditional
class state experience to make it
special for a class that deserves
nothing less thanks Megan Han to the
class of 2020 on behalf of myself and I
Mia
Calvin Nathan and Sarah we just want to
say congratulations the past couple of
years have been filled with so many
fantastic memories and experiences that
only feels sweeter to us now we've
worked really hard over the past year to
craft a celebration of the amazing
experiences accomplishments friendships
and bonds that we've built together as a
class and we are so excited to showcase
the amazing work of our classmates to
you this week this year being virtual
we've done our best to revamp the class
day experience to make it more
accessible to you all and your families
regardless of where you are in the world
so instead of class today this year
we're excited to be expanding this
tradition into a week-long celebration
we're calling class week each day this
week we will be releasing a video
covering a portion of the typical
plastic elements these videos will be
posted at 2:30 p.m. Eastern under the
class date tab of the Yale commencement
2020 website Yale 2020 led you because
this is happening over the course of a
week we hope you will stay engaged
everyday and join us in celebrating our
amazing
glass each portion of the ceremony will
have its own day and we have a little
preview of all the exciting content
coming away on Tuesday we begin the week
with George Hughes serious reflection as
she thinks about what Yemen's mean to
her and about what graduating means to
all of us on Wednesday Simon Fraser and
Oscar Lopez agreeable present us with
their extremely funny comedic reflection
on Thursday Vincent Vaughn's will give
us his IV ode and inspiring call to all
of us to recognize our dreams and fight
for them come Friday Dean Chang whopper
his remarks to the class of 2020 and
after that we suggest that you grab some
Kleenex in preparation for the next item
on the agenda which is the class history
slideshow on Saturday we have an
exciting toast prepared with some very
special guests and finally on Sunday and
we end the week with interest from our
esteemed guest speaker dr. Jean Bennett
class of 1976 as Sarah walked us through
the schedule you can see that we've
adapted certain traditions of the class
day ceremony the virtual format lends
itself to week-long festivities that we
can all enjoy together
in a virtual ceremony we found some
traditions work very well while others
are harder to replicate during most
years students and speakers sport
homemade hats during the ceremony this
year however we encourage you to
dedicate your time and supplies to
making masks for your friends families
and communities we've learned time and
time again and that the small actions
matter right now we can make that
difference with this small action
whether you decide to make masks or hats
please share your progress with the
class on social media using the hashtag
Yale 2020 and we will be sure to include
hats in our future in-person ceremony we
are also shipping a class day care
package with the physical items from a
typical class day ceremony and new
editions look forward to that we have an
exciting week planned ahead and we
cannot wait to share it with all of you
well this is not how we expected to
spend our last week we hope that this
celebration is able to bring together
the class of 2020 bridging social
distance and last time to the extent
possible we hope that your family
friends and loved ones are able to join
us to celebrate our class's achievements
memories and friendships we encourage
you to share the link to the Yale
commencement website with them and to
remember to use the hashtag yellow 2020
to share your thoughts and emotions as
you watch thank you all for joining us
this week we hope that you are safe and
healthy and we are sending you on our
love support and congratulations